now since the Universal Life qua the
simpleton the essence of the genus
develops from its side the differences
of the notion and must exhibit them as a
series of simple determinate misses this
series is a system of differences
posited as mutually indifferent or is a
numerical series whereas previously the
organism in the form of a single
individual was set was set over against
this essence list difference which
neither expresses nor contains its
living nature and whereas just the same
must be said in respect to the inorganic
taking it as an existence in which the
whole of its properties are developed it
is now the in the universal individual
we have to consider not merely is free
from any systematization of the genus
but also as the power controlling the
genus the genus which divides itself
into species on the basis of the general
determinate nosov number or which may
adopt as its principle of division
particular features of its existence
for example shape color etcetera well
peacefully engaged in this activity
suffers violence from the universal
individual the earth which as the
universal negativity preserves the
differences as they exist within itself
their nature on account of the substance
to which they belong being different
from the nature of those of the genus
and in face of the systematization of
the genus this action of the genus comes
to be a quite restricted affair which it
is permitted to carry on only inside
those powerful elements and which is
uninterrupted incomplete and curtailed
on all sides by their unchecked violence
in paragraph 294 we see angle talking
about earth meaning the entire totality
of the planet the world in which we live
and in which reason observing reason
which is right now where we are in the
phenomenology Curie zone is its
activities and carries out of its
activities in relation to all of its
objects now what is the import to this
Hegel is going to talk in this this
section about the earth imposing
violence gevalt right the the genus
suffering violence as as a result and
that's really strange language to bring
up at this point but it's revealing
something quite important to us so let's
see how this actually works itself out
because this this notion of Earth is
going to play out in some of the
paragraphs yet to come in particularly
into her nineties sense so he says what
the universal of the universal life as
simple essence of the genus develops
from inside the differences of the
notion so the universal life here has
been being treated and as the notion
that we're trying to to explicate and
we've been using this this conception of
genus got tongue and then species aren't
to try to make sense of it he says it
must exhibit these differences remember
differences they're always the key thing
for Hegel how do we tell that something
is not something else
it has differences are those differences
that really make a difference this is a
key question that has to be asked over
and over again or are they merely
notional or they've merely something
indifferent in terms of their difference
from each other that's that's the
question here so he says it must exhibit
them as a series of simple determinate
misses this series is the system of
differences posited here's an answer is
usually a different or is a numerical
series and we've seen over and over
again then for Hegel the numerical well
it is you know very powerful and that we
can
mathematize things there's a sort of
arbitrariness and indifference there
within any numerical series that
flattens everything out that you know
takes away any object that it's supposed
to be representing mathematically so any
company says whereas previously the
organism in the form of a single
individual over here right that's what
we've been working with this entire time
what's the relationship between the
single individual and its type
how does a single individual as the
expression of that type or as an
instance of that type how is it
articulated within itself an inner and
outer we've explored all of that at this
point and he says it was set over
against this essence less difference
which neither expresses and our contains
of living nature the living thing the
living organism is something free from
the the species in a certain degree it's
also something more than the species it
has concrete reality all of that is is
is now more or less getting behind us he
says that whereas the same must be said
in respect to the inorganic hitting it
as an existence in which the whole of
its properties are developed now it's
the universal individual we have to
consider and you might say well wait a
second I thought the universal
individual was the living individual and
then Hegel is is saying now don't you
remember in the paragraphs before we
showed that somehow the the mediating
term between the single individual the
isolated individual and the species was
this this universal individual well what
is that that here is where legal says
one way to understand that and the way
in which is going to be encompassing is
to grasp it as Earth Airman right so he
says here we go we want to understand
this this universal in
individual as mere doubt merely free
from any systematization of the genus
but as the power controlling the genus
so what actually you might say
conditions or it dictates this and why
is Hegel picking the earth well do you
remember that in the past we have the
animal the plants the organic life is
being to some degree conditioned by its
environment all right we did attempted
to find laws pertaining to that and we
haven't been successful so far because
we tried to place those laws over here
in the genus again in the internal
development of the thing so he says the
genus which divides itself into species
on the basis of the general determinant
of number or which may adopt is its
principle of division particular
features of its existence so number or
properties right the genus divides
itself into species if types we're not
really worried about you know a
classification here Hegel is just saying
something rather metaphysical in general
about the nature of you know larger
types smaller types and then individuals
he says that well peacefully engaged in
this activity you know this is all sort
of you know working a line there's
nothing you know violent happening he
says it suffers violence from the earth
now what does that mean does that mean
how nature is red and you know tooth and
claw and while this species is
peacefully trying to work itself out
some other species comes along and eats
it all up or landslides berries and he's
not talking about the answer of a thing
what he's talking about is the totality
of the earth teeths from this in the
face of reason that's that's examining
this and of consciousness which is
watching reason doing it's it's not so
competent show here it's going to turn
out that what seems to be important on
this side
gonna get sucked back into the earth
which is less accessible to us which is
not as available to reason as it's
studying because if it were trying to
break down earth how many is it do it
connect grasp it as a totality not
really although it's always attempting
to isn't it so he goes on he says it
suffers violence from the universal
individual earth which as the universal
negativity preserves the differences as
they exist within itself what
differences the differences that are
coming from the genus and species and
the the individual are taken up into the
earth because the earth and universal
negativity has a spot for them it has
room you might say and they really are
these differences really are what they
are only in this as yet inaccessible
domain earth which we haven't been
observing at this point so he says there
in nature on account of the substance to
which they belong being different from
the nature of those of the genus and in
the face of the systematization of the
genus so what is the comparison here why
is there violence
he says the action of the genus comes to
be a quite restricted affair which is
permitted to carry on only inside those
powerful elements and which is
interrupted incomplete and curtailed on
all sides by their unchecked violence
what does all that mean here's what
Hegel is is is sort of hinting at here
the real show is happening here and what
we have been focusing on this part over
here is really sort of a reflection or
an epiphenomenon if you like something
that is derivative conditioned from what
is in here and now we have that problem
of inner and outer arising once again
don't we except now it's not just a
of the inner and outter of organism or
you know some inorganic thing but rather
out of the totality of earth and now
we're starting to think in terms of
totality as we approach the end of this
section
it follows from this that in existence
at its structured shape observation can
encounter reason only as life in general
which however in its differentiating
process does not actually possess any
rational ordering and arrangement of
parts and is not an eminently grounded
system of shapes if in the syllogism of
organic structured shapes the middle
term which contains the species and its
actuality as a single individuality had
in its own self the extremes of inner
universality and a universal
individuality then this middle term
would have in the movement of its
actuality the expression and the nature
of universality and would be a self
systematizing development it has lost
that consciousness as the middle term
between Universal spirit and its
individuality or sense consciousness he
has for middle term the system of
structured shapes assumed by
consciousness as a self systematizing
whole of the life of spirit the system
that we are considering here in which he
has its object the objective existence
is world history but organic nature he
has no history it falls from its
universal from life directly into the
singleness of existence and the moments
of simple determinant 'no sand the
single organic life united into this
actuality produce the process of
becoming merely as a contingent movement
in which each is active in its own part
and the whole is preserved but this
activity is restricted so far as itself
is concerned merely to its center
because the whole is not present in it
and is not present in it because here it
is not qua whole for itself
there is a lot packed into paragraph 295
there's really four main movements three
of which I've got here on board the
fourth of which we can talk about by way
of comparison to this this third
movement that Hegel is is discussing the
first is this question about where
reason actually finds itself in in this
entire process here it says it follows
that that from this what we saw in
paragraph 294 that in existence and it's
structured shape observation can
encounter reason only as life in general
which however it's differentiated
process does not actually possess any
rational ordering an arrangement of
parts and is not an eminently grounded
system of shapes so when we have the you
know the organism and organisms as a
whole system of structured shapes we've
already been over this in previous
paragraphs that leads us back to this
life in general life 'über top try life
as as such and Hegel is saying that
observation remember what is observation
observation is observing Reiss right
where does reason find itself does it
find itself in the structured shapes in
the system of them provided he says no
does it find itself in the
differentiating process no because the
differentiating process turns out to
seem rather arbitrary it finds itself
rather over here as life in general so
it's looking at itself
and remember the whole global of
observing reason and the whole goal of
this reason section was a kind of
finding itself right reason was going to
find itself in the world going back all
the way to the self consciousness
section self consciousness went through
this whole process of trying to be able
to make sense of itself and see where it
in to everything and to understand
itself and then we move beyond that or
the problematics of that into reason and
so reason was this great optimism
finally we're going to look at the world
and we're going to fight it's
intelligible structure and that is going
to be you know there because it is there
but it's also there because we put it
there and we get Hinkel is is now saying
reason has to retreat a bit it's not
fine it's going through all this work
that things turned out the way that it
wanted to you might think of that as in
a certain sense a set of setbacks right
but it's also in advance to realize that
this is in fact the case now Hegel at
this point here's the second movement is
going to start talking about syllogism
again and in this case he doesn't tell
us what the actual terms of the
syllogism are he talks a lot about the
middle term and sort of expands what's
inside the middle term I think the only
thing that makes sense here is to see
the middle term as being that between
life in general and the system of
structured shapes which turned out to be
rather arbitrary not to be entirely
conditioned by this this process of what
could get at some intelligibility or
structure it's this middle term he says
the middle term which contains the
species and its actuality as a single
you individuality hand in its own self
extremes of inner universality and
Universal individuality so this middle
term would have and the movement of its
actuality the expression and nature of
universality and would be a self
systematizing development so so what if
what is the upshot of that well reason
in you know looking at the life in
general it's not really a satisfied in
saying okay that's that's how we
colonize things because that's the inner
it's the inner that hasn't been fully
developed it's not providing the
intelligible
that we wanted even if we do develop it
in terms of these forces or these you
know elements or movements like
irritability and sensibility we saw that
that doesn't really work for us right so
this seems like it's a better shot we
can make we can provide more
intelligibility by having Reason find
itself here yeah and this now is that
going to work
that's the fundamental question before
us isn't so he says here we go the
middle term would have on the movement
of it sexuality expression nature of
universal would be a self systematizing
development self systematizing
development in order to be self
systematizing it doesn't just have to
produce a system that system actually
has to make sense when observed by
reason it has to unfold itself with a
kind of necessity so hitting a little
now is ready to move to the third thing
that we're talking about in this section
here we're doing something by way of
comparison to what is actually happening
and observing organic nature so
consciousness if we're thinking about
the totality of this process in the
phenomenology consciousness provides us
with a minimal mediating term like he
says consciousness is the middle term
between universal spirit on the one hand
and individuality or self-consciousness
on the other hand now it's worth pausing
there because what Hegel is doing is
reminding us of the progress that we've
made so far right
Universal spirit if we look at the
sections of the phenomenology is not
quite where we are yet consciousness is
where we thought we began right just the
consciousness section and we saw that
consciousness is always more than just
consciousness it includes self
consciousness and self-consciousness and
it takes a while to figure out his
really individuality but then we find
out that what self-consciousness wants
is not just to be self-consciousness or
to have another self-consciousness out
there that it can mirror its off with
subjugate serve it wants to be part of
something bigger universal spirit and
that's what reason is leading us through
and that's the next section the next
huge massive section that will be going
into after we finish up with all of this
reason stuff so how does that play
itself out here he says the middle term
is the system of structured shapes
assumed by consciousness the Gestalt in
right the progress and as a self
systematizing whole of the life of
spirit so there's supposed to be a self
systematizing processor hole here
this is itself systematizing process or
hole here and how does this play itself
out he says that is actually world
history this is self systematized whole
life of spirit has its objective
existence as world history now here's
where the fourth part comes in if we're
just thinking about organic nature does
Ragab nature possess a history you might
say yes right because you know think
about the history of evolution and you
know when you go to the museum and they
show you you know the trial by eighths
and you know these these sea creatures
and then they talk about you know the
first amphibians coming out and getting
on land and all that sort of stuff and
we call that a natural history but
here's the question isn't really history
in the same sense that world history is
history I'm not going to try to answer
that question for you here because Hegel
is working that out through the rest of
us but think about the implications of
that just for a moment Hegel tells us
that organic nature has no
history why it falls from its Universal
from life directly into the singleness
of existence the moments of simple
determinate nessam and the single
organic life United in this action
reality produce the process of becoming
merely as a contingent moment there is
no necessity there we don't mean logical
necessity of the you know if a to then B
a therefore B we mean the sort of
necessity that Hegel is talking about
here where we see it developed through
how things work out in history where we
look back and saying aha now I didn't
grasp the intelligibility of this the
movement of this something less than
logical necessity but also in a sense
greater than it because it has to do
with the concrete with the actual so the
life itself they on such does not have a
history
what does in history that consciousness
which as consciousness in its full sense
is universal spirits and individuality
or self-consciousness that does having
history and that is what we're trying to
chart out here so he says at the end of
this this activity of life is restricted
insofar as itself is concerned merely to
its center because the whole will is not
present in it and is not present in it
because here it is not Quaffle for
itself so what will give us that whole
that totality that is a question that
we're still trying to answer in terms of
the organic D
apart then from the fact that reason and
observing organic nature attains to only
a contemplation of itself as universal
life as such it comes to see its
development and realization merely in
the form of systems distinguished quite
generally whose essential character lies
not in the organic as such but in the
universal individual the earth and it
sees that development and realization
among these differences belonging to the
earth in the form of arrangements which
the genus attempts to achieve
we come down to an important point of
conclusion in paragraph 296 remember
Hegel has been telling us that reason
wants to observe nature in part not just
for the sake of curiosity but because it
wants to find itself there so where is
it finding itself what does it observe
here Eagle says that reason in observing
organic nature what is it trying to
attain to a contemplation of itself and
what does it do that as universal life
as such that's really not that valuable
for it as we've seen because where is
spirits in in all of us where is the
development of the human being and human
culture and human history we're not
going to get that out of the purely
organic are we this is a process that
we're going through in order to sort of
exhaustion to show that we're not going
to get what it is that we're driving for
and if he says that it starts to them
you know it wants to try to make more
out of this it looks to the organic
systems but the problem is that the
organic systems themselves are not
coming in any sort of necessary way out
of universal life they are proliferating
and all these different possibilities
but where what is determining that it is
the universal individual the earth that
is determining them we saw that the
differences involved inherited take it
into the earth and we don't fully
understand that it's at this point
rather opaque to us another thing to
keep in mind too of course is that all
of this is actually playing out in the
same world but he's not talking about
that there that's just something to keep
in your back pocket so how is reason
able to find itself it's not finding
itself in spirit because we're not yet
there it's not finding itself in the
earth because that is still a pink to it
and it's finding out
it's not fighting itself give me is
either he said so he goes on he says the
essential character of all of this lies
not in the organic as such
but in the earth and so reason sees that
the development and realization among
these differences belong to the earth in
the form of arrangements which the genus
that attempts to achieve the genus is
merely in a reflection or if you like
the little tiny sidekick of what is
going on with the earth so we've reached
a kind of impasse here
since then the universality of organic
light falls in its actuality directly
into the extreme of singleness without a
genuine mediation of its own the thing
before the observing reason is only
something meant
and if reason can take an idle interest
in observing this med thing it is
restricted to the description and
narration of the meanings and fanciful
conceits it finds in nature this
unspiritual freedom of meaning will it
is true offer on all sides the
beginnings of laws traces of necessity
allusions to order and system ingenious
and plausible connections but as regards
law and necessity when observation
connects the organic with the merely
given differences of the inorganic the
element zones and climates it does not
get beyond the idea of a great influence
so - on the other side where
individuality has the significance not
of the earth but of the oneness
imminence in life and where this an
immediate unity with the universal does
indeed constitute the genus the simple
unity of which however is just for that
reason determined only as number and
therefore sets free the the qualitative
manifestation here observation cannot do
more than to make clever remarks
indicate interest in connections and
make a friendly approach to the notion
but clever remarks are not a knowledge
of necessity interesting connections go
no further than being of interest while
the interest is still still nothing more
than a subjective opinion about reason
and the friendliness with which the
individual alludes to a notion is a
childlike friendliness which is childish
if it wants to be or is supposed to be
valid in and for itself
in paragraph 297 we now conclude this
this first subsection of the observing
reason session of observation of nature
not with a triumph but actually with a
set of failures a set of disappointments
these are yet still advances because
something is being taken away which
could otherwise prove blinding to us or
or lead us laugh and false directions
remember what's been going on throughout
all of this reason section and what's
going to continue to go on through the
rest of it reason has been trying to
find itself in the world that it is
engaged with and it's carrying that out
first through observation and we've seen
that observation takes a number of
different forms here it's attempting to
bring itself to bear upon nature which
is organic and inorganic and it's
seeking for itself it's seeking for the
kind of intelligibility the tenth
confidence a kind of optimism about
knowledge that it itself possessed at
least you know at the start of this
section perhaps it's a little bit more
circumspect about that now and Hegel is
going to consider two different sides we
might call this the side of the the
earth which is still you know as yet now
showing itself as not that fully open to
us and a side of life itself
anything Kohana me says reason engages
in meaning mining right having opinions
about something minam can mean to point
towards a gesture at you in 10 it can
also mean to have you know have a sort
of offhand off-the-cuff opinion about
something and you know from a Gillian
perspective that's not a good thing
that's that's only a starting point
that's not what we really want as
philosophers so we want real knowledge
and so on one side we have all these you
know possibilities he says the Sun Sun
spiritual freedom of meaning will offer
and also
beginning of was traces of necessity
allusions to order and system ingenious
and plausible connections and it turns
out we don't really get these though he
says with regardless of law and
necessity when observation connects the
organic with the merely given
differences of the inorganic the
ultimate zones of climates it does not
get beyond the idea of great influence
we saw that the organic being has a kind
of freedom in relation to these
influences that are supposed to be
completely determining it or these
conditioning and that don't actually
work that way so we think that we're
getting you know necessity or laws and
we're not really getting them and the
order the system the connections that
we're getting you know they are it is an
order but it's an order that's arbitrary
rather than an order that is truly
orderly same thing with systems and
connections the fact that you can put
things into some sort of a range of it
according to numbers doesn't mean that
those numbers reflect anything real I
mean we see this happening in all sorts
of venues when people create all sorts
of really cool ad-hoc infographics that
don't really convey anything when we
when we start probing into them so he
says on the other side we're
individuality has the significance not
of the earth but of the oneness eminent
in life where this and immediate unity
with the universal does constitute the
genus the simple unity of which however
is for that reason determine only as
number right we have this again
arbitrariness on the other side whether
it's specific gravity or some other
number it doesn't matter it's not giving
us what we're looking for in in reason
reason is looking for another self of
reason within nature and perhaps perhaps
new it won't find it but it's clear that
it's not finding it as such at this
point he says you know observation
cannot do
more than make clever remarks and clever
remarks are fine if you want to joke
around if you want to engage in meaning
but if you want to get to this is a
reality of the thing clever remarks
aren't enough likewise Hinkle said that
has another crease friendly allusions
right as soon as you know you can make
all these these friendly you know
allusions to connections and all that
but he says this is no more than a
subjective opinion about reason and he
says the friendliness with which the
individual alludes to a notion is a
childlike friendliness which is childish
if it wants to be or is supposed to be
valid in and for itself if all we're
doing is to put a you know very crude
terms certainly no bullshitting around
about this sort of stuff then that's
fine we can we can do that all we want
you know we can have our CSA and the cow
says Moo and the you know the dog says
bark bark or whatever it dogs they kind
of see and say but that's not the same
thing as actually grasped me organic
nature we can come up with all sorts of
really interesting you know systems of
correspondences the ways that many
ancient and medieval thinkers and
actually some Renaissance thinkers then
it's not actually understanding nature
although it's moving towards it at least
until we have something like what we're
seeking for this intelligibility
articulated in terms of necessity we're
not reaching the prize and we haven't
reached it at this point so now the
question is going to be do we have to
abandon the quest lapse into skepticism
or can we move on in another way and of
course you know by looking at the book
since we've only gotten you know up to
this point in the blog then the answer
is yes we can indeed try a number of
other things and indeed observation of
nature leads into other ways
observing reason now we're going to turn
to the more distinctively human which
starts to get at least in my perspective
much more interesting